[Music]
all right hi everyone thanks for joining
me hope you all are having a good week
this is going to be a talk about min ago
which is kind of the story of a 20%
project it has gotten a little out of
control goodness there's a lot of you
out there so thanks all for coming so
let's start I guess with the question of
what is mini go and mini go is a open
source independent implementation of the
alphago 0 algorithm so can I get a quick
show of hands of everybody who's heard
of alphago that is a lot of a lot of
hands that's great um so the alphabet 0
algorithm was published in nature it's
the first go AI to beat a professional
human and so this talk we're gonna cover
what is mini go what is go itself a
quick little introduction to machine
learning because this is a cloud
convention I don't want to assume that
we're gonna do sort of a whirlwind tour
of the machine learning and how it
applies to mini go but what we're really
here to talk about is how we were able
to bring this to scale on the Google
cloud platform and then I'm gonna do
demo and talk a little bit about the
things that we learned and hopefully
this will be useful so to start what is
mini go where can you find it it's on
github you can check it out there it's
under tensorflow github calm or there I
guess github calm slash tensorflow /
mini go feel free to check it out send
pull requests again this is not an
official Google project I need to
emphasize right here at the beginning
that mini go is not alphago we are not
affiliated with deep mind we're not
associated with deep mind and I've coded
this entirely from from just their
published work I don't have access to
their source code and I haven't used
their source code to verify it so so why
did I do this at all if deep mind has
created alphago why why did I need to
make mini go well for starters I'm a go
player in addition to being a software
engineer at Google I also volunteer for
the American NGO Association where I
serve on the board of directors and have
worked for American NGO for almost a
dozen years now I've been playing go for
a substantial portion of my life and I
love it and alphago is amazing imagine
if you're a go player and an alien
intelligence has been created and it
happens to speak your language and
that's go players we were really excited
about alphago but of course
alphago retired so I felt like maybe I
should take a shot at trying to create
this so there's a lot of things that I
think that as go players we can do and
learn from alphago and so there's sort
of a rich vein here to explore and to
mine so our goals for min ago were to
reproduce the results and provide a
clear legible example of the program if
you do check it out on github and I hope
that you do it's only about 2,000 lines
of Python which is pretty cool for a
world-changing algorithm I hope also
that this can showcase and demonstrate
what the power of Google cloud can do
because this is basically a couple of
Engineers in their 20% time and their
spare time trying to implement this and
the only way that we were going to be
able to do that
was by using the longest lever arm we
can find
and so leverage is a verb kind of means
a different thing but quite literally
here I mean it has a a force multiplier
for what is a very small software
engineering team so where did what did
me to go come from the first so alphago
and deepmind has been described in three
papers the first paper describes alphago
and that is the mastering the game of go
with deep neural networks and with deep
neural networks and research it was
published in nature and my friend Brian
Lee wrote something called mugo or micro
go which was an implementation of that
first version of the paper he didn't he
had sort of a skeleton implementation of
it it implemented one half of the
network but not the other half and was
sort of like a proof of concept so after
alphago their second paper was called
alphago zero and alphago zero describes
a an algorithm that started from nothing
from random noise and so and then went
on to teach itself how to play go so
mixing in alphago zeroes
paper plus my friend Brian's
implementation of mugo we get min ago
and if you're curious about why mini
goes logo is a happy looking robot
falling off of a ladder all will become
clear I will explain why he looks
completely at ease with this situation
where he's falling off of a ladder
alright so let's talk about what the
game ago is how many people have played
go anybody here wow that's a lot of
people how many people like to play go
yes that's exactly what I like to hear I
I love go I've been playing go for a
long time I really like it so we're
gonna do a quick quick demo of what go
is this is what it looks like at the
beginning people take turns putting
stones down on the board trying to
surround territory when we talk about
capturing capturing looks like this when
stones are completely surrounded they
get taken off the board that also works
on larger chains of stones so you can
see that groups that are connected
orthogonal II share their fate where
they will hang or hang or stand together
as it were the winner is decided by as
you try to divide up the board whoever
has more territory wins that's it so
it's like you're drawing up lines on a
map you're carving up I get this you get
that you can see on that on the right
diagram there that white has surrounded
all the triangle points and black has
surrounded all the squared points
this means that go is not really a sort
of absolutist game where you have to
like capture the enemy king or
completely destroy the enemy our enemy
it's more like you're negotiating an
agreement well you just want to get a
little bit more than the other person
and this is an example of what a whole
game might look like so this is this is
mini go in action you can see it
sketching out territory starting in the
corners and this pattern that you see
happening right there that is called a
ladder ladders are an interesting
example of why go is hard so this is a
fairly straightforward pattern you can
see it develop again it's a really
obvious pattern it's a pattern that you
know toddlers can probably follow and
predict but it's an example where go has
a very long horizon effect where the
result of that ladder could decide the
outcome of the game
and it may require looking 80 to 90
moves ahead and so why why is that hard
so a ladder is this great example of a
game where you have where even with a
branching factor of only looking at two
moves for each of those cases you're
already looking at you know a t-square
or two to the 80th excuse me possible
positions so that very high branching
factor makes things really difficult the
games are really long the end condition
is really hard to describe so with go
you want with chess when the King is
captured a checkmated the game is over
and everybody can see and agree this
game has ended with go the game is only
over when both players agree that
there's nothing left on the board worth
contesting this is pretty difficult if
you're trying to teach a computer how
the game is over in fact just scoring
the board just knowing that it is time
to score the board is a really hard
problem and then lastly and this is
possibly the most important part is that
it's really hard and go to determine
who's winning in the middle of the game
this is one of the so this problem who's
winning who's going to win one of the
hardest problems we have dealing with
the branching factor that there's so
many possible moves at every point one
of the really difficult problems that we
need to solve and so let's take a step
back and let's talk about how we're
going to approach this with machine
learning so this is five slides about
machine learning obviously this is not
an exhaustive explanation I should
mention also this is probably good time
none of us have PhDs on the mini go team
so there's probably people in this
audience who understand this better than
I do but bear with me I hope that this
will be enlightening for folks who have
maybe not done any machine learning
before at all so real quick inference
for neural networks so the basic idea is
we're going to put in an input and get
out an output and that thing in the
middle is the model that we talked about
we don't really want to worry too much
about what it is except for we need to
know a couple of things about it the
first is that it's a bunch of math that
is differentiable or close enough to
differentiable and the second is that
it's really slow like slow on the order
of milliseconds to evaluate and why does
that matter that it takes milliseconds
that seems
fast well because you maybe need to do
thousands of those before you can decide
on a movie play so we're gonna consider
neural networks for inference inference
meaning this forward path where we start
at our input and we get out our decision
that's what inference is it's also
called a forward pass
we need to know that it's slow and it's
differentiable alright so how do we
create that model that thing in the
middle well what we're going to do is
we're going to try and quantify the
error where we have inputs that we know
and outputs that we should have gotten
and we're going to take a look at the
difference between those and try and
change the model which is differentiable
so we know which direction we need to
push the different values in that model
to make the error smaller so that's
basically machine learning in a nutshell
release the stochastic gradient descent
form of machine learning but yeah it's a
pile of linear algebra and we're gonna
try to tweak it and we can repeat this
process where we try and make the error
slightly smaller until we run out of
data that function that model in the
middle could be a function of many many
millions of variables so we're
essentially trying to minimize the loss
of you know million variable functions
and that's pretty complicated but
luckily there are pretty good
abstractions for doing all this stuff so
let's keep going so what is inference
from min ago and how are we going to use
that to solve this problem
so inference for min ago in this case
means two questions what moves should we
play who do we think is going to win so
given that board that you see on the
Left that's our input and we're gonna
ask mini go for a probability
distribution of where it thinks the next
boom is going to be and we're also going
to ask it for a number that expresses
who it thinks is going to win
so min ago uses negative 1 for if white
is gonna win and positive 1 if black is
gonna win 0 says way too close to call
perfectly balanced and anywhere in there
from negative 1 to 1
is it quantifying who it thinks is going
to win so given those two outputs what
is the move that we think is going to be
played who do we think is going to win
we do something called Monte Carlo tree
search
that my friend Brian Lee who I mentioned
wrote mugo did a great talk at PyCon
20:18 called a deep dive into Monte
Carlo tree search with code also our
code is on github Monte Carlo tree
search is really great super easy to
read and highly recommended so that deep
dive in a Monte Carlo tree search is
great so by doing this self play with
Monte Carlo tree search we're able to do
to quantify our error so we asked min
ago for what moved to play and who was
ahead and now we can define our error as
the sum of the difference between the
original estimate for what moved to play
and the moves that were actually
explored by tree search so we use that
estimate of who's going to win to decide
whether we continue to explore that move
so we'll look at this move then we'll
look at the next most likely one under
it and if it's better or worse maybe we
won't explore that parent move does that
make sense kind of maybe can we can we
just sort of acknowledge that this could
happen and we can dig into the details
at some later point all right so that's
Monte Carlo tree search which move in
who's ahead the two components which
move and who's ahead are called the
policy and the value outputs of the
neural network so policy is a given a
board state where do I think the next
play is going to be and value is how do
I value this board all right so let's do
the quick recap that was our fifth slide
so this is our summary slide this is how
I get six slides this is a reinforcement
learning recap the lightning version of
reinforcement learning is using our data
to make models using our models then to
make more data and now we never run out
of data and we can keep doing this as
much as we want so what's the model the
model is that pile of math that we had
in the middle we want to be able to
measure that loss by comparing it with
answers that we know or with answers
that we think we know we train a model
by minimizing that error so and min ago
uses the policy and value to do tree
search to try and refine its original
estimates does that make sense
maybe somebody ya know
okay well we're just gonna move on the
reinforcement learning loop pretty
simple it's this nice virtuous cycle
that we can set up we're self play makes
better data and we use that in training
to make better models and they reinforce
each other the problem is that that I've
made one of those errors substantially
larger and that's not an accident
because the idea is that using doing
tree search involves doing many of these
inferences or forward passes we want to
do as many readouts as we need to be
able to ensure that we're improving our
policy and that means doing maybe
hundreds or thousands of inferences per
each move now if we can train on each
move that means we're doing hundreds or
thousands of inferences per training
data point that we make so at a minimum
we're going to have this this ratio
where we need to do hundreds to one in
terms of making inferences versus making
training steps does that does that sort
of setup the problem here so in order to
train adequately I need to do this for
millions of games and I know that a game
will take on the order of minutes even
when I'm using GPUs or TP use so my
question becomes how do i scale this now
happily this is a problem that is to
borrow someone's phrase embarrassingly
parallel setting having a having two
copies of mini go play each other does
not involve any other copies of mini go
which means that I can spin up as many
of these as I can assuming I have a good
way to shift to shard this all out or
scale this all out and so that brings us
to the part of the talk that I think
well here for which is using this on
Google clouds so we used kubernetes to
do this but we started by making the
smallest possible units of work that we
could so our training job was pretty
straightforward and we made our work our
job use cloud storage as a way to sort
of coordinate what we needed to do this
worked really well cloud storage as it
turns out is incredibly flexible and you
can abuse it in all sorts of interesting
ways we were able to use cloud storage
to get this sort of tracer bullet while
we're sort of deciding do we need to
write
centralized server do these need to talk
to a server at all and cloud storage
basically scaled to the point that we
didn't really bother so it's it stood up
wonderfully and we've been able to use
that probably beyond the the limits that
we certainly thought we could so then
what we did was we turn this into
containers so we used we use docker to
build containers for that self lay
worker and we used kubernetes to scale
this out to thousands of nodes so we did
this we could start off we could fetch
the latest model we could write out our
data we could shut down and start up
again and each since each time we're
fetching the latest version of the model
we're always able to coordinate and make
sure that we're generating new data with
the latest and best model that we have
so what we originally did was originally
wrote this on a smaller board size so
the original diagrams that I showed you
at the beginning we're go being played
on a 19 by 19 board that is the
full-size game of Go Go is also played
on a 9 by 9 board and this 9 by 9 board
is a lot simpler the model for that is
about 250 times faster so we were able
to sort of verify correctness using that
smaller model on a smaller board and I'm
using correctness very loosely because
it turns out machine learning is very
good at finding patterns in your data or
patterns in your data that you didn't
mean to put there it's very good at
covering up for mistakes that you make
so we saw something get better on our
smaller sized board that had really
glaring horrible bugs that we wouldn't
discover until later but more on that
the next thing we did so as after we did
this and verified our correctness on the
smaller board we realized that holy cow
the full-size model is going to be 250
times slower we need to add accelerators
and so we were able to hook up GPUs with
a minimum of us
we were running a cluster of about 2,100
GPUs with no problem at all we using
GPUs on kubernetes is fantastic it means
we don't have to worry about drivers we
didn't have to make any code changes
what ran on our workstation will run
perfectly on
on kubernetes on kubernetes engine and
this was a this was pretty great success
but it was still a little slow we had
some benchmark performance numbers that
we were trying to hit so the numbers in
the alphago paper detailed that they
were able to perform sixteen hundred
inferences in point four seconds we were
about 40 times slower than that which is
okay for a solution that was Python and
for our accelerators which were not TP
use but 40 times slower meant 40 times
slower they were able to Train
play five million games in three days
and if we are 40 times slower than now
I'm looking at doing that this taking
three months so that's a little
challenging I needed to find a way to do
this more faster so before we do that
let's take it a little step and say that
as I'm setting this up on GPUs and I'm
realizing this is going to take months
to run I really wanted to find ways to
verify that everything was working so
with containers it was really easy for
me to make variations on the jobs I was
running and really try to run other
sorts of evaluation matches it was
really easy to use the kubernetes engine
API to spin up jobs that were variants
so I could test different version of
models make sure that I'm making
progress this was a really important
thing that I'm going to come back to
later
and when I say measuring performance I
am measuring performance on my tasks
which is are my models actually getting
better at playing go that's a real
question so early on I knew that this
was going to take three months at the
point that cloud tea pews were being
developed I said hey you know this might
work really well if I could try running
this on cloud TP use and the cloud TPU
team was pretty enthusiastic and they
said yeah sure go right ahead um but
they were so much faster that it meant
really really written my pipeline for
reference the 2000 sheepies that I was
using we're a few generations old so I'm
deliberately avoiding making any sort of
direct numerical comparison but suffice
to say that what was previously fine in
Python was now no longer fine using a
cloud TPU there was no way that the code
was going to be fast enough
which meant that if I was going to be
able to use these TP use effectively I
would need to seriously rethink how this
pipeline was going to run when you're
planning on something taking three
months and now you're looking at maybe a
week or two you have some very different
constraints about how long you can take
to pre-process your input data how long
you can take to you know lazily push out
the results of the new models all that
sort of thing so what we had to do is we
had to rewrite 40p use this code is
Monte Carlo tree search this is the
short pseudocode for Monte Carlo tree
search and I'd like to draw you
attention to that line that says neural
net evaluate leaf dot game state because
that is the one that suddenly this this
whole thing needed to go in parallel and
it needed to go in parallel a lot faster
than it could and so this was the part
that the engine that would do this
rapidly was the part that we needed to
rewrite so that's what it looks like on
a single threaded version this is pretty
close to what the Python code actually
looks like in mini go today and so
rewriting it for TP use involves
involved breaking this out into a
multi-threaded version friend of mine
volunteered to do the C++ rewrite and he
he's probably not gonna like me telling
this story but he was able to write this
complete multi-threaded implementation
no problem no bugs
writing a doing a full rewrite
multi-threaded code no bugs no race
conditions no problems like that but he
had forgotten to actually increment a
loop and was left with a brutal bug that
took days to debug I was like I'm so bad
I'm like you just did a complete rewrite
multi-threaded code that had no bugs the
first time you couldn't be harden
yourself of that anyway so this is what
it looked like we ended up building a
container out of our C++ port that would
spin up a Python engine and we would do
these RPC calls when our queue had
enough nodes in it to run them all
through the model and this did great it
also meant that our C++ code no longer
depended on tensorflow so we didn't have
to have any trouble building tensorflow
which made our builds a lot quicker
which is pretty cool
and once we had this engine now we could
change to using deployments on
kubernetes engine previously when we
were using GPUs we use the batch API
quite show hands people have used
kubernetes before in this room cool oh
that's great the batch API worked really
well with two thousand nodes we had some
interesting limits around tracking
completions and what we ended up doing
was not bothering we ended up writing
our job as a job where we set something
like a hundred thousand completions and
what that would actually do is it would
throw away completions after about a
thousand which meant that it would just
run constantly which was what we wanted
the completions writing it as a batch
API worked really well because that
meant that it would just always retry it
would handle the retry logic for us that
all worked really well but now with
cloud GPUs we didn't want to pay the
price of having the containers go down
and come up again so we wrote them to be
long-running jobs as deployments and
this all worked really well we didn't
need to track completions anymore
because we were writing these as
long-running jobs and so this all just
basically worked out of the box
one of the advantages of mini go is that
we were able to test this so so many go
is entirely public it's all available on
github which meant that throughout this
entire project I was following the exact
same path that external customers would
follow
so as although I'm a Googler I basically
was going through the exact same process
that anybody in this room would have if
they tried to go through it and that was
a pretty great experience honestly I hit
way fewer and and also a lot of these
were while these products were pre-alpha
or you know getting ready for alpha and
the experience was honestly amazing
cloud TP use on kubernetes engine had
basically worked out of the box ditto
for the GPUs like I said the driver
problems were not even a thing that I
had to worry about so if you're thinking
about doing ml or accelerated computing
on kubernetes engine I basically only
have good things to say about it so so
that's pretty great so
do a quick demo of min ago I think
there's a way for me to make this play
but I don't know what it is there we go
I like it so this is min ago thinking
about this particular game this is that
small sized board I think this was
actually running in CPU only on a laptop
it may even have been a Chromebook so
this is running completely unaccelerated
on that smaller size of go that I was
telling you about
oops and it doesn't loop which is
unfortunate but you can see the
variations that it's considering in the
upper right what it thinks is the most
likely move to happen in the left side
and this is a pretty great tool if your
go player you can really dig in and see
what it's thinking about why what it
likes what it doesn't like pretty great
alright so talking about our results
alright
so results okay so talking about the
conclusions and the lessons learned I
kind of want to talk a little bit about
the trends here that we've had which is
moving from GPUs to TPS and in this case
these were older GPUs to the new the
newest GPUs has been eye-opening the
ability for us to do more work with
basically the same amount of electricity
means that us users have our incentives
aligned with cloud providers to use the
newest and fastest hardware basically
there's no reason that we want people to
use the older versions of the hardware
because the newer versions of the
hardware will do the same work will do
more work with the same wattage which
means that we really want you to use the
newest thing that you can so as long as
this holds you there's going to be this
pressure for us to make our code go as
fast as possible and this is fantastic
in particular when you're doing research
if you're trying to dial in these
solutions you need to be able to
experiment as quickly as you can you
need to be able to try things that might
have been too expensive to try otherwise
and so having this push to use the best
price per performance and having the
price per performance be use the fastest
thing not use a slower thing means that
we can really dial in the models that
we're trying to build that we can really
you know iterate faster on how we're
going to test the various ideas we have
for how to develop models but what that
means is that means you should plan for
your pipeline to get faster again we had
originally bracketed that this would
take us a couple months and now we're
looking at getting it done in a week or
two and that changed some of our core
assumptions about how long we'd have to
do a lot of the different steps in that
pipeline and it seems like that's only
going to continue so definitely you want
to plan accordingly that is the cloud
edge TPU which is the little USB gum
stick on which we're going to make mini
go run which I'm really excited about in
relation to this idea that your pipeline
is going to be faster we really want to
try and make our models more like cattle
and less like pets have you guys
familiar with a cattle not pets metaphor
from containers some folks may be
getting the idea the idea being that
containers lets you reproduce the exact
build of the software you're running you
can say that my server is
interchangeable that I can get more of
them I don't need to give it a name it's
not special it's not a big deal if it
dies or goes down or breaks and I have
to rebuild it in the same way we'd like
our neural network models to be like
that as well where if it takes you three
months to do it you get kind of
possessive like you really don't want to
see anything happen to it but if you can
make a new one in a day or two now you
have this freedom and ability to
experiment and try things and it means
that you can keep those changes much
better isolated with our early runs on
GPUs that were taking months it was very
tempting to constantly monitor the
dashboard try and tweak some knobs try
and turn some dials here and there you
know and worry and fret over it but it
also meant that at the end of that
process how could I reproduce exactly
that sequence of things that happen
really hard having it all go faster
means that it's all a lot more
repeatable and that's pretty great
another thing that's pretty interesting
here is that these reinforcement
learning systems really resemble
distributed systems so I imagine a lot
of folks here work in the cloud and
they're familiar with the idea that
you're in
visually well-behaved systems stop being
well-behaved in tandem and that's pretty
interesting from a number of reasons I
think that there's sort of two ways that
we go about analyzing why our systems
are doing the wrong thing one of them is
from the code up where we can look at
the code and understand exactly what
will happen and the other way is from
the behaviors that we see down where we
have to think about what's happening and
you know generate a hypothesis and say
okay if you know the load balancer is
doing this then we would expect this and
I can test that this way maybe you can't
solve that just by looking at the load
balancers code and the server's you know
you have to you have to generate a
hypothesis and test it and that those
are two very distinct steps I think it's
inductive versus deductive and in a very
similar way neural networks and
developing neural networks have the same
problem where we're not you can't
directly point at a line of code for why
model makes a decision it does but you
need instead you created code that made
that model which means more of the
top-down type of debugging you still
need to be able to look at specific code
and try and figure out what's going on
but in this way these reinforcement
learning systems really resemble a lot
of the distributed systems and the idea
that debugging is a process of
generating hypotheses figuring out how
to test a hypothesis in isolation
you know verifying okay well I did this
I expected this this other thing
happened what does that mean for my
intuition about how these systems are
working all right so let's sort of wrap
things up a bit
there's two major parts of this the
machine learning part and the software
engineering part and I'm trying to focus
in this talk mostly on the how part how
did we get to 90 petaflop s-- you know
how did we monitor health how do we get
the performance that we need how do we
make it work I haven't touched basically
any of the machine learning parts why is
the network this way why are these
constants like this why is the network
structured like this
you know those why questions those are
pretty tough but we can't really answer
those wise until we have the house
nailed down so if you have your neural
network your machine learning problems
that you're trying to figure out the
answers to these questions obviously you
know those are going to be
domain-specific but when you say okay
well how am I going to deploy and test
these applications how am I going to
test my hypotheses you know the answer
there has been cloud platform that's
worked fantastically so let's talk a
little bit about the things that did
work really well so I've included a
little stack driver dashboard that we
used stack driver was fantastic we could
just throw things to standard output and
you know reg X through them without any
trouble
I mentioned cloud storage also scaling
way beyond the level that we talked at
so our early clusters were putting out
maybe 50,000 games a day with a
full-size model with TPS we're putting
out over a million games a day and still
having to download and handle them all
and cloud storage has just been a champ
at some point we're thinking about doing
integration with cloud BigTable but
that's still TBD and in the meantime
cloud storage has just been we just
abused it it's really wonderful to
Bernese Engine and cloud GPUs as I
mentioned those basically worked out of
the box if you're interested in using
them it's a it's a pretty great
experience definitely sign up what you
need to do tensor board 1.9 has the
latest release of tensor board will let
you serve your tensor board dashboards
right out of cloud storage which is
great if you are trying to use the cloud
to use the profiling tools are easy to
use they're useful to dig into and find
out how you can get the most performance
out of those TVs so all of these parts
of you know using the cloud stack went
really well as for those wise I love
this quote here from Alex or pan
reinforcement learning is really hard he
has this quote if it's if it turns out
random I have no idea if it's something
I did or if I just got unlucky right we
have some of these algorithms in the
state of the art and machine learning
right now that may be a correctly
working version with a different random
seed will not converge on a
solution and that's kind of astonishing
that here's a successful result that's
been published that only works 30% of
the time obviously alphago zero seems to
be much more robust but it kind of
points out the challenges in testing
these hypotheses and the need to be able
to iterate and isolate and and sort of
formulate hypotheses and see if they
work
this is kind of an amazing quote that
that I really liked to think about for
me personally I've been following in the
footsteps of published papers where I
know what is possible because deep mine
had published their papers it would be
much harder for me to like just trying
to imagine if I was in their shoes where
I get a model that turns out pretty good
but not great and I say to myself well
can it be better or is this the best I
can do with this approach right there's
a very big difference between exploring
the unknown and reproducing the known in
my case if I hit a ceiling I can compare
that ceiling to the ceiling that they
described and say okay well maybe I
clearly have a bug whereas for somebody
doing new research for the first time
it's going to be much harder for you to
say
is this the ceiling or do I have bugs
you really need to be able to be
diligent and controlled and and make
sure that you are able to isolate the
parts of your system and make sure that
each of them is doing what you think
does that kind of make sense great
awesome and lastly I kind of want to
quote about why I'm really excited as a
go player that all of these things are
finally taking shape
I started min ago and after the alphago
paper was published which I think was
November of last year and since then
Facebook has announced an open-source
version they've just released a model
$0.10 and other Chinese companies have
been working on models which they've
released with various degrees of
openness and it's been very exciting to
have these and an open source project
called Leela zero has also been done
where they've been trying to crowdsource
all of the GPU compute needed and it's
been really excellent to have
all of these different folks try to
reproduce the paper with varying amounts
of success and its really wonderful as a
go player to have access to these
essentially Oracle's go players like to
think of playing a game of go as having
a conversation talking with someone we
have a great proverb that playing a game
of Go with someone is like living with
them for a year and in that case we have
this new thing that is saying new
creative ideas to us that we haven't
really understood before so if you are
interested in learning more about the
game of Go definitely check it out
online there's a lot more resources and
hopefully it's going to be a lot easier
to learn now that we have ways to
understand it we do try to hang stories
on our moves that we play and it's going
to be a little bit easier for us to sort
of do that and understand that as we
have better tools to dig into so thank
you all very much a big thank you to the
folks who have helped Jenna donate their
time to work on min ago that's Tom Seth
Brian and Josh they all have been
instrumental in making me go possible
you
[Music]